thank you for this insightful book
excellent sheep which has been
provocative in higher education circles
and I think among students and families
it's a terrific contribution to the
literature and I'm grateful for it
the nation should be grateful to you for
it all of a series of questions okay
about it if you have and I'll Stratton
maybe the more difficult one
it appears you didn't receive tenure at
Yale right you had a great run you did
wonderful work you didn't mean now is
that in the book I'm wondering why not
well I think that that's a question
that's come more often from fellow
academics who wonder whether this book
is a product of sour grapes I think
specifically it comes from from people
in the Ivy League I didn't want to make
my story part of it any more than I
needed to the book is really for general
readers for students for their families
perhaps in retrospect it would have been
a good idea just to get that out of the
way and I'm glad that you asked me so I
can get it out of the way no one of any
sense who's a junior faculty member at a
place like Yale expects to get down here
at a place like Yale I didn't I'm not
angry at Yale for not giving me behind I
left academia because I wasn't able to
get a job somewhere else and the main
reason for that is that jobs and
academia are drying up because
increasingly schools are hiring adjuncts
rather than professors so it's really a
larger problem that's part of the things
that I talk about in the book absolutely
true and I'm sympathetic though yes I
just wanted to know I'm glad I'm glad my
that's right understand that yeah that's
the circumstance from many many
professors yeah
interestingly you know I'm at Georgetown
so it's a German Catholic University and
I had a particular interest in that
domain and you you only mentioned one
Catholic University in this book
Catholic University of Chile actually so
I was wondering if you think that none
of the Catholic universities in the
country either are elite or you don't
know that domain or we don't have the
same kind of student bodies that Yale or
the Ivy League's have no it's not that I
mean I do mention a fair number of
schools in the course of really talking
about what students have written to me
and what fellow professors have told me
about things that there's
little but it's to a certain extent it's
a bit arbitrary who I mentioned it who I
don't it's not that I think the elite
Catholic universities of which
Georgetown Notre Dame BC clearly are
among its not that I think things are
radically different there because it's
all one system and the main aspect of
the system is the kinds of students that
are being produced before they even get
to college it's really about the
admissions process now as you know I
have sort of a half a paragraph in the
book where I say that I think that in
some ways religious colleges and that
would include the prestigious Catholic
universities do things better because
they're still paying attention to the
higher purposes of a higher education I
should say that that line about
religious schools seems to be one of the
ones that is most annoyed Ivy League
professors not not most readers but
people like Steven Pinker who are just
incensed that the idea that that the
word religious and the word good could
be in the same sentence so well I would
I would tend to think that religious
schools and Catholic and Jesuit schools
do have a value added in what they do
and I think at our place that there are
we are kind I'm trying to shape students
for life and I tell parents for example
you've given us a gem as any of these
elite schools have and we polish it and
give it back to you with a with a
conscience the responsibility to give
back and the ability to lead and that's
what we do and what I want your students
to be your sons our daughters are better
versions of themselves when they leave
here oh they'll also be smart they were
smart when they came in and they'll have
a Georgetown degree or they'll have a
Yale degree 11 Harvard degree of course
that's a given for these students it's
it's what happens at the margins and
what I'm really at the center of
themselves is the more important right
than simply the credentialing I think
evidentially will happen and if I even
earn that right so that's really not
what I'm interested in but right now I
realize families are interested in this
and students are interested in
credentialing as well but we have to
open their imaginations to something
beyond that listen I think the most
disheartening thing for me about the
reaction to the book is that I've said
as you can as simple paraphrase I've
said many of our most elite schools are
not giving students what I would call a
real education
is what you just described and the
response has often been from within
those institutions or people who
recently graduated not yes we do give a
real education but who wants a real
education these days don't be a sucker
this is about job this is about career
this is about return on investment and
the kinds of things you just talked
about that it's about life and not just
about your job this is an increasingly
difficult argument to make and it's one
of the main reasons I wrote the book to
try to push back against this intensely
pragmatic and I would say self-defeating
ly pragmatic idea of education in
general and higher education in
particular as I think for example
liberal arts schools are designing
professional schools are designed to
teach you how to make a living
liberal arts schools that teach teach
you how to live a life and why life is
worth living the larger questions and I
think I can give you an anecdote a story
of a student of ours who was an art
history major and was presenting before
one of the boards at Georgetown alumni
and parents and so forth and was being
pressed by one of the board members why
would you do what are you going to do
with that
what are you going to do with an art
history what are you gonna do it she
expressed how its enriched her life
completely it'll probably stay with her
for her life she has an aesthetic sense
it was a very eloquent very eloquent and
he pressed again but what are you going
to do with it and she said well if I
have to for a profession I'll fall back
on my second major which is neuroscience
and that's often the kind of students
I'm sure you saw but certainly that we
see and my own view is that I agree with
you completely you should pursue your
passion in branch many people don't do
it i but I think you should pursue your
passion but I'm a pragmatist too so for
example you can be a history major or an
English major but also I put in a minor
in business for college students a minor
so that you can know how to read a
spreadsheet and do because no matter
what you're doing even what I do I'm a
Dean I'm doing management and I'm right
seeing budgets I'm an academic right by
training so I haven't given up that core
of Who I am but having other requisite
skills is helpful but it's not something
I think that that the liberal arts
student should pursue a full time in
under
experience right I want to be clear and
I hope I'm clear about this in the book
I'm a pragmatist too I do not want
students to think that the world is
going to hand them a living because it I
was in the living but there's a
difference between compromise and
capitulation right figure out what you
want to do figure out what you care
about the most and then figure out
hopefully with the help of college how
you're going to translate that into a
career that can sustain you but it's
also I mean it's also important for
students to know that it's not just
about the first job and if you look at
people who have been successful
especially people who've been successful
and done interesting things it's almost
never a linear path and that's why I say
even in narrowly practical terms this
pragmatic approach is self-defeating
because you want to prepare people to be
able to navigate a career which means
having all these kinds of intangible or
soft skills that you don't get from a
technical education or from a business
minor you get from learning how to be
the kind of person and be the kind of
thinker that a real liberal arts
education gives you someone I heard
recently described a liberal arts
education as intellectual cross-training
that's a good term right because it's
not about majoring in English per se or
our history or whatever it's about and
only America does this right
only we allow students to take classes
insist that students take classes across
the curriculum so they're learning
different ways to think and therefore
they're better at each of those ways
because they've learned all of the
others I I agree I think in tributes to
certain agility mental agility and
flexibility and and I distinguish
between a job and a career and a career
will last actually you'll have more than
one career most people have more than
one career you might be in multiple
careers over lines you'll certainly have
multiple jobs and if the if the the
measurement is exclusively your first
job and and the salary attached to it
it's probably not an accurate
measurement of where you're going to go
in your life if you measure liberal arts
people 10 years out and 15 years out
they think they seem to do equally well
with people who are trained in other
skills usually on the financial I
believe there's a study that says that
but the gap closes and it does it does
close so I so I think and for me these
are four years where you could explore a
range of issues that I think in my own
view have intrinsic value
somebody pragmatic value but intrinsic
yes yes and that will that will that
will inform you and shape us who you are
so I we couldn't agree more on that one
thing we try to do you also talk in the
book about how practical and driven for
credentialing students are and not
reflective often and I think that's true
I think they they get in they they're on
a treadmill to just get to the next
thing and fill the resume out we we try
to have them have we could the judge
color can a contemplation an action that
you step back and we we have a retreat
center in Virginia away from the campus
where we take them and the retreat
center doesn't mean a religious retreat
there are religious retreats available
but one is called escape it's simply
getting away for a weekend and
reflecting on what are you doing here
why are you in college what does it mean
independent of the pressures from your
peers right there you'll have a small
peer group with you and and someone to
guide the conversations but also away
from your family and away from what you
why those those weekends are
transformative for many students they
kind of figure it out I think oh this is
this is I need to do this more often I
need to reflect I believe that their
transformative I think it's great that
you guys are doing it I do wish that I
had mentioned that in the book that I
have known about it and could have
talked about it because listen I mean
what I do say is I don't have a lot of
practical suggestions to make because I
don't know you as an individual and of
course but the one thing that I say is
you need to step away whether that means
a gap year before college so that or
whatever it is it's it's precisely the
act of getting away from the peer
pressure the parental pressure the the
incessant busyness that comes with the
the drive to credential to credentialism
the hoop jumping right now college in
general used to be should be it's
supposed to be that in itself right
college in general is supposed to be the
four-year time out right but it's been
so pervaded by these by these pragmatic
pressures by these this credentials arms
race its I insofar as I blame the
colleges for that it again goes back to
the admissions process and how it
creates a child in an adolescence that's
all
about jumping through the next tube and
then secondarily that I think unlike
what you just described at Georgetown
many colleges and I think many
especially elite colleges don't do
anything to disrupt the momentum of the
hoop jumping I think that they think
that because our kids are so smart and
of course they must be smart because
there SAT scores are high they must be
smart because we let them in then we
don't need to do any of that work of
getting them to be reflective about what
their education is really for they take
it for granted I think that's a huge
mistake
yeah I agree I think it's a I think I
think with that's value-added we have to
do that yeah we have to force them into
that kind of a thought process that kind
of reflection that kind of conversation
with others about what is the meaning of
all this I think it's the foundational
question you have to do and we have to
come back to it again and again it's not
always easy and you're fighting a
certain pragmatism and they're all so
diffused in all their interests they're
doing many many things yes you know
they're they're doing internships and
they're there they're volunteering and
they're taking five courses and they're
in three groups and they had two of
those groups and this is this is a
typical of it what would you say for the
strategy when you're talking with
families and all and it's easier to do
it at our place that it might be at Yale
or other places I'm not sure of the
double major so for example I often
advise students listen pursue your
passion in college or you said in the
book yourself doing your passion people
don't do it as much anymore I still
think you should because there are four
very privileged years you can never get
back right and you'll never have a
chance to do this kind of reaction again
and the kind of reading and and writing
that you'll do in college but pursue
your passion in one major and do to mom
and dad's major if you want it for the
second major or the one that's going to
set you up from a professional career
I'm fine with that I'm quieter being an
English major and a biology major you
really want to be a doctor but you want
to be kind of well-rounded well-read
thought right what do you think of that
well I'm not against it I know it's
become very common the kids will say one
for me one for my parents right I'm a
little skeptical about it again it can
be the right choice but I think it it
misunderstands the role that this
passion or interest is supposed to have
I don't think it's something that you
should just do on the side because it's
a neat thing when you're 20 years old
but yours you're going to
you know it should be the foundation of
what you do in life again compromises
will have to be made I've made
compromises I'm sure you've made
compromise it's the world will demand
that of you but I think we need to start
from a place of I actually try to get
away from the word passion because it
partly could become such a cliche and
students feel like oh I don't know what
that feels like
I prefer the word purpose hmm because
that unites the inner with the outer
what what what what what do you care
about and what do you see out there in
the world that needs your attention to
the extent that it's possible and this
will differ for different kids different
circumstances that is what should
motivate what you study in college and
what you do afterwards so I'm not I
don't like this bifurcation right I mean
that's exactly where we start to get
into trouble where we think that life is
over here and work is over there the
idea is to find the kind of work if you
can that's going to that's going to
reflect what you care about most deeply
and listen they're also surveys and I
think common sense tells us that that's
gone also going to lead to the most
successful even in vocational terms kind
of existence you know if you want to get
out of bed and do what you're doing and
it's meaningful to you the psychologist
will also tell us that the two main
constituents of happiness are
connectedness to others and this a sense
of purpose which which for us in the
21st century generally means purpose
through work right this is true right
something that it's purposeful and
meaningful work yeah you said that is
remuneration is good or maybe excellent
but shouldn't be doing something that's
worthwhile yes doing good while doing
well in a sense yes we would hope
shifting a little bit there's so many
ideas in the book I have my head is
filled with things I want to ask you and
one is the Great Inflation issue I think
at all schools across the board but not
necessarily every school I think
certainly the elite schools clearly have
a heavy grade inflation yes in our own
place the students are you been
complaining about it ironically real yes
they are they're saying we want a
clearer differentiation between who is
really outstanding and who is good and
we're not really getting that from our
grades the grades are very high
for everybody and so how do we how do I
know if I really am on saying that I'm
outstanding I mean how I don't know in
meritorious more than the next person or
I stand out in any way if we're all
teeth on a comb on the GPA scale it's
interesting they've said that now as a
consequence when they say that if the
GPA goes down they'll be the first ones
to complain and say right we didn't mean
that
right I mean that would affect me but
it's an interesting argument because
increasingly a large number students are
gaining Latin honors at all the elite
schools very high very high percentage
of right many of them who merit they
come in highly qualified it's not
unusual but we're thinking about
restraining that yet and students are
actually saying some are saying that's a
good idea there's a saying oh I might be
left out and therefore I won't be
competitive for graduate school or other
profession your take well I first of all
that's such an interesting thing because
because as you know Princeton went bad
by this they tried this and and despite
the fact that apparently there was no
evidence to lose disadvantaging their
students after graduation the students
were so freaked out by the possibility
that it was that they insisted that they
go back to the old inflated grade that
you know the average GPA like north of
3.5 all right what's especially
interesting to me about what you said
about your students is that it it
resonates with with the sense that I had
as a professor and I've had speaking to
students since then that they they want
honesty they know that the system
they've become so cynical about their
education because it's always been so
much like a video game like just get to
the next level and because they know
listen one of the things that's driving
Great Inflation is precisely this this
ridiculous busyness this extra the way
extracurriculars expand to fill all the
available space whether in college or in
high school how do students deal with
that how do you deal with the fact that
you're doing ten different things sport
musical instrument whatever and you
still have to carry a course load you
put more and more pressure on your
teachers in high school or your
professors in college to inflate grades
but this that this is part of what
contributes to the cynicism and the
sense that students get that they're not
getting real feedback and they don't
really know where they stand
and I found students often to be
surprisingly grateful for honest
feedback which I tried to give them you
know which i think is good and honest
great hard grades I think the best
professors are very good pedagogues
they're very good they're inspiring
teachers and all but they're also
demanding and I found the students who
find that they got the B from this
person the only B they got they think it
was the best course they had yes where
is the easy a so to speak is it's okay
because hear that a lot you hear that
from people who've been at school for 10
years that the professor they remember
these are the ones almost again it's an
exception and as you say great inflation
is an increasing problem and it speaks
to the fact that learning is not at the
top of the agenda in college anymore
yeah that's can be a problem C can be a
problem I mean you know people also talk
about the mutual non-aggression pact
between students and professors right
right
they prefer illusion among the professor
sometimes well because professors are
incentivized not to teach but to do
research so it's easy it's much it takes
much less time to give someone in a that
it does to give them a B because if it's
a B you have to explain it to them and
then you have to help them get better
that's right and that's the the key part
and I think that's the important part
it's helping them get better I mean for
example the whole notion of a rewrite
which yeah is a good idea I think that's
because that's how you learn to lose say
okay here's your mistake let's try this
again yeah and but it's a it's it's it
takes a lot of takes a lot of work it
takes it takes an investment in the
frames and say if that's your primary
mission you're really there to enhance
student learning yeah yes but if usually
most places have a dual mission of
course Institute enhancing student
learning but also producing first-rate
scholarship it's a challenge look look
this has been a contradiction in
American higher ed for a very long time
there are forces we could talk about
them academic job market forces that are
making it worse and worse and as
students shift their attention away from
their curriculars to their
extracurriculars it becomes more and
more of a problem no one no one is
really no one's primary interest is
what's going on in the classroom the
professor's want to be in the library of
a lab the students want to be in their
club or their internship so we need to
think about
think about this yeah that's probably
excessive say no one there are still
people who care about classrooms yeah
right performance but I know that but
the direction is that way and speaking
of that curricula and all what do you
think of the the the efforts to change
curricula through technology and MOOCs
and and all that's happening away and
that kind of that why domain you don't
address it too much in the book but I'm
sure you have some opinions I have a few
choice paragraphs about the most but I
don't I mean as you pointed out I try to
cover a lot of ground because I want to
describe what I think is a large system
that needs to be the parts need to be
inventoried but I can't talk about
everything I don't want to try to talk
about everything look as a general rule
surely there are ways that technology
can enhance learning as another general
rule I think Americans prefer to solve
problems with a machine than with a
human being
we prefer technology to teachers or
psychologists or sometimes even parents
education is a human relationship it
always has been I really think it always
will be I don't think we will ever be
able to teach people as well by turning
them loose on a computer program then we
will one-on-one in small classrooms with
teachers who are who are rewarded for
for teaching people think that they can
solve the cost problem in college
governors politicians think that they
can solve this problem with MOOCs with
massive open online courses with
technology with efficiencies of scale I
think it's a huge mistake and as I'm
sure you know the the completion rates
at MOOCs are dismal they're in the
single digits even among the people who
finish MOOCs they tend to be older
people who already have college yes the
vast majority of them have degrees
already they have degrees because they
do it for personal edification rather
it's not the democratization of
Education this is and making it more
accessible to people's not about hate in
Outer Mongolia
right and it's not just that they're
doing it for personal enrichment they've
been to college so they already know how
to teach themselves through the whole
point of college is to learn how to
teach yourself this is very true but you
can't you know you can't do it by
yourself no another slight shift again I
I had a transfer student whom I
restoring to a Georgetown wonderful
young woman and she had come from a
school that was should I say this sounds
arrogant not elite but it was certainly
it was a yeah very ordinary kind of
place yeah she's very bright she had
gotten into several very good schools
including Georgetown and Columbia and
Chicago and but didn't have the money
you know and we gave only eventually we
could give and it wasn't enough so she
went to another school thinking that a
good student can get a good education
anywhere and she found it not to be true
in the particular place she went to
she's come to us and it's been a much
richer environment right both for the
pedagogy but also I think for the for
the peer group that she's with and that
they're actually serious about education
that they are ambitious that they work
hard that they do their reading or all
of that they're conscientious right it
makes a difference the environment is if
you want to be academically inclined
this is okay this is a culture where the
other culture was it was not a good
thing to be academically inclined so I'm
not sure that it works everywhere I
think in other words elite schools do
have something to offer to students
listen uh III don't disagree with that I
mean I don't I'm not gonna romanticize
or idealize public higher education as
it exists now to me the ultimate
solution is to refund public higher
education to make once again the
commitment we once made to have high
quality low or no-cost higher education
a public higher education
um but given the state that things have
reached at most public universities
because of the relentless defunding yeah
I mean kids have trouble graduating in
four years because they're closed out of
classes classrooms are giant lecture
halls there's there's no contact there
aren't even graduate student teaching
assistants the
elite private schools are very well
resourced institutions and they can
offer students the opportunity I would I
would even say they always offer
students the opportunity to get a great
education but at a lot of schools and it
sounds like Georgetown isn't one of them
but certainly a lot of the Ivy League
schools are like this you have to fight
to get the kind of education that the
school is supposedly set up to give you
because your peers by and large are not
interested in what's going on in the
classroom and your professors by and
large do not want to take the time I
mean people have written about people at
Harvard have written about this people
at UVA have written about this one of
the public Ivies you have to fight your
institution and I'm simply saying first
of all that's ridiculous and second of
all there are schools where that's not
the case I single out as an
institutional model the liberal arts
colleges hmm colleges that don't have a
large university edifice where where the
where the where the emphasis is more on
teaching and they still defend the
liberal arts a lot they're also now
public honors colleges more and more of
them that try to replicate that model on
large public campuses to me that's what
a college would look like where a
student feels supported by the
institution and their peers for once to
get a real education not like a sucker
because you should major in econ and go
to Wall Street hmm the advantage of
potential and all the small liberal arts
colleges that do that I admire them they
do it well and the elite ones get the
best students but the the advantage
might be for a student who goes to a
research university that has a call
liberal arts community they get they get
both in a sense they get access to
high-quality research and a high power
institution that way and they hopefully
get the personal attention and the the
teaching that is required in a college
environment it's a balance but there are
some places that try to try to do both
listen institutions differ I think at
the University of Chicago which has this
great reputation for intense
intellectualism I also think about the
fact University of Chicago seems to be
departing from its mission and I don't
know if you want to get into this but
party careful is my alma mater well
listen I mean you should be concerned
about this and I hear this at other
places too Brown which is of the Ivy's
the one that's most like a liberal arts
college I hear there
also there's an institutional
convergence there's an institutional
homogenize ation partly driven by USNews
and various other practical factors or
not practical factors where more and
more colleges are looking more and more
like each other and and they're
converging on that research university
model in the in the worst sense where
it's all about research humanities gets
shrunk as you know until it's small
enough to drown in the bathtub because
science is what brings in the money or
supposedly brings in the money and so
forth yeah they do look amatis I mean
Chicago I went for graduate school and
it's a state was at that time two-thirds
graduate and one-third undergraduate so
it's a kind of a high power research
institution I think it sees itself that
way it has put more resources in
undergraduate education and probably
done a better job in recent years but I
think you better be singly focused when
you go there what you're going to be
doing well may be true with the other
schools - yeah I mean I don't know if we
want to talk about Chicago too much in
particular but I see it differently I
mean it's always had I think a deserved
reputation for for for a very again a
very intense intellectual experience
sort of like a graduate school for
undergraduates exactly you know that's
that's what they seem to be moving away
from because a lot of kids don't want it
and you know they've changed their
admissions policies and dropped their
acceptance rate very far they're very
happy about it but it seems like the FOS
that made it its own unique place is
getting on well that's something good
saying something that's unique as a
sense there isn't a lot of
homogenization across higher education
to be unique is not easy to do to be
distinctive I think you can be
distinctive sill and some certain places
are but unique is probably not a term
that we would use for higher education
because we do look a lot alike many of
us it doesn't mix I mean maybe you
couldn't explain this better because
you're in the management end but it
would seem to me that you'd want to have
a differentiated product absolutely I
mean that George trying to say because
we're judgment Catholic we're in
Washington DC
we're not Berkeley we're not brown those
are wonderful institutions right happy
here's we are we also have a an embedded
value structure that we're very clear
about and it's us one of the phrases
that the school is men and women for
others so we expect you to give back
it's just part of the culture this is
who you
is to give just a large to the common
good is what we expected them when they
come in as freshmen any minute when they
leave as seniors they understand them
what that means
as a consequence one of our biggest
employers is Teach for America you'll do
service for two years and the end some
will stay in the education domain but
others will go on to other things I
think it's a good thing people are
actually doing something worthwhile yeah
the post-graduate world would you advise
sometimes for example I advise students
who want to pursue a passion we have
this is happening more and more for a
media industry they want to go to
Hollywood they want a big screen rising
right right I think that's okay I say go
for a couple of years put parameters
around it and if you're getting coffee
for a director eight years later you've
got to get out of it but at 22 I think
you should experiment I think you should
be you should be free to do things I not
feel constrained that you have to go
immediately to get your MBA or your JD
res some students feel right again it'll
depend on what circumstances dictate and
maybe your student debt load will
dictate but listen you know you haven't
experienced the world yet until you get
out of college so how are you going to
figure out what you want to do in the
world until you have some exposure to it
I agree with that and especially if
we're talking about you know a law
degree a business degree it's I think
much better done when you're a little
bit older I agree and I think maybe
taking a little bit of a risk is a good
thing at some point it's okay it's okay
I mean you don't want to take the risk
when you're 35 and you have a mortgage
and your family or you have
responsibilities but when you're 22 you
cannot just do the thing I take it's
essential yeah
and part of the problem is right these
kids have been taught to be risk averse
from the very beginning because they
know that they have to get that perfect
GPA to get into the name-brand college I
mean risk aversion is one of the things
that people who've been I'm not the
first person to write about no I'm
ashamed it's one of the main things that
people have identified for a long time
and I think it's something that we
really need to worry about just one
quick thought we're preparing students
for an increasingly unstructured job
market economic world with an
increasingly structured education right
so this is not serving them well
mmm what about the professorial how do
you think that's changed in the last 20
or 30 years no education professor is
I'm it's a fancy term for all those
people who are hired and no no it's a
great it's a great term i contains its
own melancholy i think the most
important thing to say about that is
that at this point only 25% of people
who teach in college our professors are
tenured or tenure-track tenure or
tenure-track professors the rest are
adjuncts postdocs graduate students or a
very large class as you know of
full-time non on track this is kind of a
shadow this is a way that schools have
gotten around tenure without saying that
they're abolishing tenure hmm listen a
lot of these people are great teachers I
would say especially the full-time
writer you're an adjunct you're teaching
at three or four places you're getting
$5,000 of course it doesn't matter how
committed you are to teaching it's going
to be very hard for you to be a good
teacher these longer term contract
employees are often the best teachers on
campus but they are still not rewarded
I mean salaries are still low job
security is low institutional validation
and prestige I mean everybody knows that
they're second-class citizens I think
it's time that we got serious about the
idea of a teaching faculty in parallel
with a research faculty or I mean
either/or right you are hired promoted
and tenured either for your research or
your teaching or some combination of the
two not just research as it is now hmm
we already have this second faculty but
we need to we need to give them the you
know we need to pay them and and and
respect them equally to the research you
know the research stars I would agree I
think we need to record them the respect
and give them the visibility for their
career give them a commitment from the
institution to some degree and they will
be more deeply committed to you and they
often are deeply committed to you the
other part the research I would I would
like to still the research faculty to be
active in teaching I think that they
should be doing both I think if strictly
a
faculty you really have a two-tiered
structure and a two-tiered University
and yeah and sometimes those who other
research stars are they never see a
majority of the students they write
their classes are small they're harder
to get into their graduate only and
therefore students who know they're
there don't have access to them right
like to see my ideal is you teach at the
undergraduate level even introductory
and and in elective and you to the
graduate level you do both and not not
exclusively one or the other I mean only
teaching undergrads when you want to
graduate seminar with with high-power
students I get that right only doing
that and shooing the undergraduate
enterprise and saying others can take
care of that I won't take care of itself
I mean I need really a thright research
active cutting-edge people in the
classroom with our college students
right but I mean you know the economics
the institutional structure has been
pushing the OP in the other direction
look I mean why there's why what what's
cause the adjunct if occasion of the
faculty it's a cost-saving measure for
universities as I understand that the
the segments of the academic budget
that's grown at the slowest rate is
institutional costs I'm sorry is
instructional cost in other words
there's you're not spending that much
more in teaching than you were 20 years
ago the football stadium the football
coach the football team the fancy
dormitories at the debt on the money you
had to borrow to pay for all of these
things it has to do with this move to a
consumer model right we now see students
as customers who have to be appeased
what's going to appeal to an eighteen
year old to get him to bring his tuition
dollars to our campus listen these are
long-term structural problems there are
also problems people have been aware for
a long time and it seems that all they
do is talk about them but you're also
this is from the administrators yeah
yeah they're also providing a large
industry infrastructure for people
you're basically providing a city yeah
where you know a profession doesn't
require that you with the exception
perhaps of military that you have to
house your people and feed your people
and entertain you all the things that a
university is we sure do these days so
it's a big thing yeah it doesn't have to
be eller elegant but it has to be
present yeah you need to have the dorms
creates a culture for people to be in no
listen I mean you need you need dorms
and you need cafeteria the question is
what what what that was it exactly yeah
how elegant and all no but I think it's
not as it's it's not as he immediately
obvious to the eye when you have the
equivalent of of a dowdy dormitory in
the classroom in other words an adjunct
professor who's you know cigarette is
not as evident but for some people in
the public they don't understand what it
costs to run a university and I know
there they say there's runaway costs we
go beyond inflation for for our
increases sometimes but it's a very
resource intensive enterprise to run no
it's it's expensive most schools end up
spending more per student than they
actually charge in tuition even though
most people would not know that no I
know it's and I think people also don't
have a loss leader should we say no it's
true I think people also don't know that
real costs for students have actually
been flat at private universities for
about ten years
right I mean tuitions have increased but
the actual sticker price that they're
paying has been seated it's been almost
flat for ten years it's continued to
rise quite significantly at public
universities because we're defending
them right we are and I get that and
probably at some public public
university presidents will say I work at
a state regulated but not a
state-supported University and and
that's changed very much since the
land-grant university time unfortunately
because we have very high quality public
universities in America many of them and
and they're underfunded and it's
difficult to do it so therefore it's
carried on the backs of out-of-state
students yeah paying the hard way yes
yeah that's listen to me this is the
most important issue it's the fact that
we have transferred the burden of paying
for higher education from the taxpayer
to the student and family so instead of
taxes we have student debt and if people
want to see who's responsible for the
trillion plus dollars in student debt
they should go and look in the mirror
that's no really this is imagine the
taxpayers won't agree with you on that
no of course not because taxpayers want
something for nothing right so we're not
spending on our physical infrastructure
and we're not spending on our
intellectual infrastructure so what do
we think we're going to get people need
to make the connection between what
happens to them as taxpayers and what
happens to them as parents well this is
the dilemma also if you live in a state
with
refine public university and it's
competitive then you've paid taxes and
then your kid can't get into that
university because it's now become elite
that's another issue you've paid it and
now your student doesn't have access to
what you paid for
I hadn't thought about that but I would
argue I would question the idea that
there are any school any states that are
supporting their public universities to
the extent that they should all I mean
look at the University of California
which was this you know it's facing
severe hardships financially yeah yeah
and downsize in some cases and raising
tuition but yeah other other state
structures to larger especially large
structures with that are very capital
intensive its aren't hard to keep them
going that's why we're about the elite
schools isn't it well and it's also why
there's such a crazy stampede to get
into the elite private schools this is
true as long as the elite private
schools can provide you know just Gailen
orison need-blind meet full need so that
the kid who comes from a somewhat
disadvantaged economically disobey that
ground has access to this education
which for me is a moral value I think I
think it would be shame on us right if
George has not opened to all students
and not simply the economically elite
well it is but at the same time these
schools have very low admissions rates
right so here families know if I can get
the kid in then it'll be taken care of
but that's that's the whole it's a
narrow gate to get the pin you get in
and I don't think we'd have the same
pressures if parents knew that they
could send their kid to UVA or Berkeley
or wherever for nothing and not just or
for you know a thousand dollars a year
and not just you Vieira Berkeley you
know Mike's my slogan now I believe
China had a slogan of 100 Harvard's
they're going to build 100 Harvard
equivalent I think we need to build a
hundred Berkeley's we need to have two
or three of those in every state so we
don't have every high school kid in
America competing to get into one of 12
schools and some of those Princeton for
example you can go for free I mean if
you get it right because their financial
aid policy is so generous and the Galman
is so rich yes but if you get in troops
you want ax great greater access but you
also want standards for these schools so
they'll still be composed sure well
that's why I don't want us to have to
rely on those schools I mean let's be
clear about this for the low-income kid
who can get into Princeton or Harvard
it's amazing it's like 3 or 4 percent of
their student body right our kids from
the bottom quarter it's small so we're
not talking about a lot of kids now
we're trying to increase ours of
first-generation students we have a
program for an additional scholarship
and not only scholarship a mentorship
program for them so when they come right
they are mentored by students were there
and by alumni in all kind in in social
etiquette in in negotiating an
environment that is very different from
the one in which they came so they're
comfortable right there they're bright
enough to get through it to do well but
there are other cultures there are other
cultural issues that are very
challenging for right and we need to
provide for that and and only if you do
that can they be successful if you don't
like that they flounder on other domains
right absolutely and I think that's you
want them to have you know a good
experience a positive experience and a
rich and full experience but you've got
to provide a lot for the I agree and I
think we should I think that I think we
have responsibility to do that I agree
but I just want to emphasize it's
admirable that you guys are doing that
other places are doing that we're never
going to be able to educate the bright
low-income kids enough of them at the at
the private private school right we need
to be right I mean it's just a question
of scale right we need to expand that
the capacity in America for these kind
of students and I think that that's
going to mean publicans public
universities I mean there are hundreds
of thousands of smart poor kids who
never get to college at all right they
need to be able to go to their state
institution for you know for a nominal
cost and get a good education some have
taken the route and it's not a bad one
of doing the kind of Community College
route right and two years at a much
reduced cost and then transferring to
the flagship university often it's a
good policy I think it's a good idea and
yes I agree under scalar agree and a few
and a few locations I think Tulsa is one
of them and perhaps is it Tennessee that
are trying or have already
installed a policy of free free
Community College so it's again it's
free it's the beginning of returning to
free public higher ed it's gonna cost a
lot of money I just gonna cross Londo
yeah look what what do we want to spend
our money on as a society yeah yeah well
what are we willing to invest in and
we've seen that American higher
education has slipped a little bit in
the kind of national international
rankings we use although we're still
desirable it's just like our health care
system if you have a lot of money it's
the best in the world and people from
around the world send their kids want to
come but in our college completion rate
used to be first and now it's 12th right
we need to take that seriously and if
you look at how many how many years it
takes to complete college I mean at Yale
and George sounds for years for
virtually everybody but at other schools
is five and six years and part of that's
not access to the right classes Prada
vets they have to work while they're
there and it's just it's an end it's a
burden they're funding issues right yeah
funding issues yeah there are both
issues that there's not enough classes
for everybody in certain lives right and
that's the institution's issue and then
there are the economic issues that are
challenging right but the fact that
there aren't enough classes is also a
funding issue right yes and no I mean
girls I mean well maybe I mean if you if
you allow a major to be the major right
exclusively and you don't direct people
though the majors of course they'll very
don't never be enough room for econ
majors right now as you suggested it
look everybody's do like the lemmings
they're going in that direction and
right it's a there it's a fine
discipline all but it's not the
exclusive discipline in college it's not
what everybody should be studied right
exactly everybody should have there
should be a wide variety of things right
now it's important I mean if we're going
to talk about that it's important to
emphasize that it's not just humanities
that have been suffering because
everyone's being told to take the
pragmatic majors econ engineering
computer science basic sciences there's
been a huge drop in majors in basic
sciences physics chemistry geology this
is really going to cost us and it's
because students are being steered by
all kinds of pressures including our
president saying don't major in art
history they're being steered into econ
and business and an engineering we have
been I mean the National foundations
like NSF and so forth have defunded a
lot of the research that's done for
basics
Sciences and it's very competitive so
it's hard to maintain a good science
faculty who are able to garner grants to
support the research that they're doing
that stable although we have seen a
significant uptick in stem students at
our place politically in biology very
very high right right we had 2000 Apple
we had 12,000 applicants for the college
for 850 places last year 2000 home of a
biology we mitigated ninety yeah I think
biology is something that people want
we're always doing very well and right
that might be the bent Mac path the
pre-med but it's also the path to a lot
of interest right BIOS Hicks sure I owe
- words that are so that has not
suffered so much but some others physics
is has has declined somewhat but physics
was never the most popular major in any
campus itself was never the most popular
very self selected but but if you look
at what they call the physical sciences
which is basically science - biology
there's been a huge drop and and yeah
part of it is because we're not funding
basic research but that's that's sort of
not an answer that's more of a problem
now and we need more people this again
it's about not making the investments
that are going to keep us prosperous
strong and free a generation down the
line when are you going to run for
Congress so that you can change this
because you and I sitting this table
will not be able to change that dynamic
I'm afraid ranted we would like to but
really it's a political solution it's an
economical but sebelum I absolutely
agree and we probably don't have the
clout to make that well no one has Joe
no individual has including the
president United States apparently I I
think five years ago three years ago no
one would have foreseen the the movement
towards the minimum wage towards raising
the minimum wage getting the kind of
traction it's gotten that's now as you
know in the last election just passed in
several red states I think that free or
low-cost public higher ed needs to be
put on the agenda right next to raising
the minimum wage as a way of addressing
the enormous problem with inequality
that we finally woken up to in this
country now that we know we know now
that the debt bubble is that's been that
was propping up our prosperity has burst
everyone's looking around in the ruins
realizing we have a huge problem with
inequality and social mobility so that
means raising the minimum wage and it
means
making education accessible again
there's an organization called it's got
a terrible name it's called redeeming
America's Promise it's a terrible name
because it doesn't tell you what it's
about
but it was started by a former a to Vice
President Gore and some other of his
political friends and this is their
agenda right it's free public free
public higher ed so the movement is
starting I want more and more people to
know about it I've listened I'm a writer
I'm not going to be a politician or even
an organizer but organizing is what
people need to do and again I want
parents to make the connection between
what happens to them as taxpayers and
what happens to them as tuition payers
and to realize that they have a stake in
resurrecting public higher ed I think
parents are there if anyone is going to
make changes it's going to be parents
acting as a group because they they're
fed up as many of them are with what's
happening with their kids with the kind
of crazy pressure that their kids are
suffering under there's a documentary
called race to know air that it's been
circulating in communities for a long
time gets shown at high schools parents
come they talk about it it was made by a
woman in the Bay Area who's actually a
lawyer and her inciting moment was what
her for fourth grade son was complaining
of stomach aches because he was so
stressed well about how much homework he
had and she said you know there's a
problem here she started to talk to
other parents you know so that's that
that's what I'm talking about I think
that's where the change will come if it
comes at all the stomachache comes in
more economically advantaged
neighborhoods I think other
neighborhoods the stomachache will be
over other things that the stomach is
empty and that's the absolute I mean she
says she's a lawyer she's never
middle-class parents schools are failing
in other places yeah on the political
side if you if you if you take your
argument what do you de fund or what do
you not fund and when you when you
redirect funds to public education I I
would raise taxes listen listen not the
top one thing that message will go over
well with everybody in America it's
again you know what you know what I'm
just
old enough to remember the Reagan
Revolution nobody in their right mind
would ever have imagined that that could
have happened ten years before it
happened that we would drop top marginal
tax rates from 70 to 28 or 35 I the one
thing I'm certain about with respect to
the future is that we can't be certain
about the future and things that seem
impossible today like raising the
minimum wage will not will will be
possible tomorrow listen there plenty of
things that I think we spend too much
money on whether it's prisons or defense
or corporate welfare but we our tax
rates our historical lows the share of
national income that goes not the top
one percent of the top ten percent and
that includes me and I'm guessing it
includes you and many of the people we
know is a historic highs we're talking
about a transfer of a couple of trillion
dollars a year from the bottom 90% to
the top 10% that's the tax target that I
think we need to go after and I don't
think we'll ever have enough money for
our public needs until we do I think
people in public education will thank
you I think others will say I know is an
impossible mandate I know yeah it's it's
a dilemma it's very difficult to fund
everything at once so yeah and
priorities I don't believe it of course
you know that yeah you know them here I
agree at the same time the private
schools will continue to exist they'll
still charge hefty tuitions right
there'll be robust they'll have high
demand I don't think that's going away I
just don't think that's going away
that's there couldn't be all the sector
separate tracks well it's part of the
two Americas we're creating I mean
people live in gated communities with
private security forces send their kids
to private schools and universities and
they go to Yale is this yes that many of
them go to you is this the listen I know
this is a cliche but is this a country
we want to live in right I certainly
think most people don't because most
people are at the short end of the stick
right people are not on that privileged
position that's right sure
all right although some of the people
with whom we deal are in that privileged
position their families are in there
absolutely it's absolutely all those
kids have a right to be in these schools
too they've earned it they worked hard
and they've done very well so I don't
want to disenfranchise them and say own
we'll only take the person who was some
way disadvantage to being part of our
ecosystem that's not fair either no so
it's a balance and let's be honest you
can't afford to because this model of a
private issue wires rich people paying
tuition students and Families no
question about it well I want to thank
yes it's a robust and and stimulating
and insightful conversation and I I'm
all I can say is I'm looking forward to
your next book okay thank you very much
you